uh so another principle focus oversight
on the controllers not the controlled i
think most people would agree with that
um
and and that's one of the concerns of
today is that we're trying to
focus a lot of attention on on
folks who are
not exactly uh behind the steering wheel
in a lot of cases
we've we've and you say that everybody
agrees on this but we've engineered a
society with exactly the opposite
principle right i mean it's like in in
pandemic workplaces where you're working
from home or whatever you there's new
technologies that actually some
companies have put like sensors in the
chairs to make sure that the person's
actually sitting there i mean it's so
dystopian and and yet it's not like
enron was brought down by you know the
person taking a five minute extra long
lunch break it was it was the people who
weren't being watched who were
embezzling or cooking the books or
whatever and so you know my point is
that
with the responsibility of leadership
comes extra scrutiny and yet we have a
lot of the surveillance mechanisms of
modern society trained the people who
can do the least damage and i think it's
very bizarre that we've come up with
that system it makes sense because the
people who are setting up the system
don't want to be watched themselves but
you know the idea of like keystroke
logging for employees i mean
if you're going to roll that out for the
employees you better roll it out for the
ceo too i think wow that ceo would veto
that [ __ ] and be like what you're gonna
monitor my keystrokes
that's right through that brian
everyone's keystrokes now
are anonymized
i decree it um i just want to go on the
record and say if i were the incoming
prime minister of the uk and i was given
that choice i would uh write in the
envelope that the submarine commander
should do what they think is best
because i feel like they can process the
situation they can get new information
uh they can see what the most
appropriate action is i mean you've
given someone
control of a nuclear submarine like you
have to kind of assume that they
have a pretty good head on their
shoulders they're commanding you'd
assume also dozens of people
uh under seas for a length of time so
anyway just wanted to suggest that that
would be my move um
you know what i mean like
i just seemed like the best choice to me
um
there i'm going to tell a story now
about your next principle which is you
say to utilize randomness to
increase security with
minimal invasion of privacy and i'm just
going to tell a quick story
i was a camp counselor
at a camp for uh you know maybe like 12
year olds 13 year old something like
that i was 19 or 20.
um and so the deal was that
uh i was on duty every other night
um but the campers didn't know which was
which
um
you know like i i was on duty for half
an hour after lights out every night but
then every other night i could do
whatever the hell i wanted after that
time
um and so me and whoever was off duty
would go out and like go to tgi fridays
and get some drinks and the rest of it
um but i just remember what an effective
deterrent it was because to the kids it
was like i was always there like like
they didn't know i had every every other
night off um so
like that like i love the idea of like
like look you just need to insert some
randomness in there and just introduce
the possibility that someone could be
there and then all of a sudden people's
behavior will
improve yeah so so the i love that story
because it jives really well with the
one that i talk about in the book which
is the um the conversation i had with
the former head of internal affairs at
nypd and he set up these
drug stings where you know they've got
they tell this guy to like go and
babysit to crime scene where there's you
know a ton of cocaine on the table and
twenty thousand dollars in cash but
nobody's been there so they see what he
does does he pocket six grand and then
report that he seized fourteen thousand
dollars what's amazing about that story
though is that they have 500 of these
they do they do 500 sting operations
then they survey the cops and they say
how many of you were subject to a sting
in the last year
and 12 000 cops say they were subject to
a sting and the reason for that is
because if you put out 500 some of those
people are actually going to encounter
real situations where there's drugs on
the table and money on the table and
they're going to think it's a sting and
it starts to create this sort of
impression of like maybe this is just a
setup and there's some sort of healthy
dose of of
sense of you know potential consequences
the the really funny thing about that
study though is they they had um they
had like people which it's an amazing
job you can imagine the nypd they had
people like go up to cops and try to
like provoke them to punching them so
they would like they would like insult
them the course of the cops the
insulting pedestrians sting
it's it's right and like and if they if
they punch the pedestrian uh they would
you know face consequences or get fired
or whatever and it's just like but the
value of this is that because it was
random the effect of it was much much
higher than if they'd actually said you
know oh we're gonna do 50 sting
operations this year because then the
uncertainty doesn't exist now i don't
want to live in a dystopian society
where like the the break room fridge is
like baited you know to see who's going
to take the the sandwich but i think for
people who are in immense positions of
positions of immense authority or
positions that are prone to abuse that
the occasional threat of random
oversight is very very effective i've
got it
members of congress just get offered
money at random
and then
in some cases it's like busted
and so then when members of congress get
offered stuff they'd be like oh i can't
take this
huh
am i fixing things
well you know i don't actually think
that's like the stupidest idea i think
that there's something i think there's
something to the so in the uk right now
there's this sleaze scandal they call it
where
lo and behold the people who got the
contracts for a lot of the covid
services of testing and so on happen to
be people that were friends with some of
the ministers you know i don't actually
think it would be that bad of a thing to
occasionally plant
you know fake contractors i'm into it we
should i i wasn't really kidding we
should totally just have like freaking
fake
fake real estate deals and other garbage
in there you know big stock market tips
fake
pandemics
be like hey
you know and then see if they buy zoom
stock and then you're like busted
um this pandemic wasn't real
the last three were
so
now i mean these systems
would be very very helpful i mean a lot
of them spoke to me as very consistent
with human behavior uh and a lot of them
you can actually try and marry a
political reform too
i'm going to close with your last uh
principle
which i thought was very very powerful
and correct which is stop waiting for
principled saviors make them instead and
this is really the point of your book is
that look you have people you have
incentives and systems
and if you're waiting for superman to
come along then you know it's probably
not going to happen and oh by the way
superman probably couldn't fix this [ __ ]
anyway
so you need to do is you need to try and
actually make the system
attractive
and
the kind of system that will attract and
empower the right people yeah i mean i
think this is the this is the ultimate
answer to these problems that we've all
identified i mean we're unhappy with our
leadership class we're unhappy with the
people who are seeking and obtaining
power
so why don't we do anything about it you
know i mean we can we can just do hearts
and hope and
yeah exactly
so
we could we could wait and hope that
there's going to be some
massive
you know wave of good leaders that just
sort of stumble upon our lives and and
fix everything that would be great if
that happened but i think we need to
think very very carefully about how you
engineer systems to ensure that those
people end up in power
and you know what i've been baffled by
is like why don't we have that
conversation like we always have
it's our media brother media doesn't
give a [ __ ] about what you're talking
about our media just wants to piss us
off about the the the person's wrong
action or wrong statement of the day and
then we can decide who to get mad at
tomorrow who to get mad at the next day
um you know our media just whipsaws
people and their sentiments
um and a corrupt system doesn't make
good
cable news
well
that's what i call like the tip of the
iceberg problem which is like you've got
this whole phenomenon around power the
systems the people who don't obtain it
under the surface the tip of the iceberg
is the people who are in power and it
makes sense to focus on them they're
visible they're they matter you might
crash into them but i think that that's
all we focus on you know we don't think
about the the system the people who
aren't making it into power the
introverts the the the different you
know candidates who couldn't possibly
win office because they don't have 12
million dollars in the bank you know
this
and and i think this is where
smart reforms can make a better world i
think that's the the really important
take and it's where i you know see eye
to eye with with with a lot of what
you're doing is
this is something where we can change it
we're not like beholden
to a world where we just think our
leaders are corrupt and bad and
self-interested and narcissistic
you get the su you get the people that
you have a system made for you know a
rotten system attracts rotten people a
good system attracts good people and our
system is rotten so
the the answer isn't to just sort of
berate the people who end up there it
makes sense we're going to do that
anyway it's to actually make the system
good so that we don't have to do that in
the end and i think that's the ultimate
answer to this this big problem of how
power corrupts people and how
corruptable people get power i agree
with you 100 we need to focus on the
mechanics of the system the incentives
it produces
uh it's why i'm doing the work that i'm
doing which is trying to diminish the
power of the extremes and power the
reasonable
somewhat silent majority
uh yeah so it's one reason why i enjoyed
your book so much i am going to suggest
something to you that you know it's
something that troubles me and this will
be our closing note like right now the
the system is run it attracts rotten
people it makes reasonable people
less reasonable over time and more
rotten
um and now there's this real dubiousness
where if someone comes along
um we just wanna tear them down and i
will say that right now the media is
very much
animated by this energy it's like what
someone's trying to do something like
let's try and shiv that person in some
way
and because
you know they have to be corrupt and so
we we're going to show how corrupt they
are and this by the way is one of the
things that's dissuading a number of in
my view pretty good people from doing
something like running for office is
because they know
that to the extent they have any
foibles or dirty laundry it's going to
get dragged out for all to see
you do have an environment where you
know that there was a woman alexi
hammond who tweeted something that
people didn't like when she was a minor
i think she was like 17 and then she
like loses her job over that
um and so like in that environment uh
it's one of the concerns i have frankly
is like so you have this rotten system
you have this churn and then if someone
comes in now there's this impulse it's
like oh like let's let's tear this
person now what's wrong with them what's
wrong with them uh and so you have this
increasingly incorrect mess
where
uh that your trust just gets lower and
lower
so i i suppose i'm doubling down in your
case where this change this sort of
change is very very much overdue because
it's contributing to the loss of trust
you know this is something that i
grapple that'll grapple with a lot when
i was writing the book because as i said
before i sat down with some really
unpalatable unpalatable people
but people are really complicated you
know i i wish that we could have that
conversation where it's just like
there's no
uniformly virtuous person and no
uniformly evil person for the most part
in our society a lot of shades of grey
yeah and and i think this is something
where you can have that grown-up
conversation you can say look we're not
looking for a saint we're looking for
someone who's going to make the world
better and that's something that i think
is is a really important recognition
because
otherwise you have a sort of random
effect too right like
randomly somebody who has a a terrible
view when they're 16 years old happens
to tweet it somebody who's 16 years old
doesn't tweet it says it to their friend
and one of them gets destroyed in one
dozen i mean that's that's that's
randomness right and it's it's something
where i think we don't want to engineer
systems where we insist upon 100
mistake-free leadership i think that
also people who make mistakes learn from
those mistakes so
to me you know i i grapple with this and
how i wrote about people who i don't
admire because some of the people in the
book that i sat down with i think did
some really vile stuff but i was trying
to convey
that they're they're dealing with
different pressures they're talking to
different systems they're navigating you
know a culture of power that's different
from ours
and
maybe we would behave similarly if we
were thrust into that position but
instead what we like to do is say oh
they're bad we're good you know and i i
think there's something
much more complicated going on where it
would be better for us as a society if
we didn't want to have somebody who was
100 perfect but instead was working hard
to make a system
better for the rest of us because that's
ultimately what the goal of politics and
power should be
[Music]
you